so up in canada the convoy of truckers
converging on ottawa to keep that nation
free is going larger by the day they
left from vancouver on the western side
of the country on sunday they're
protesting the federal government's
vaccine mandates for cross-border
truckers among other things that mandate
took effect on january 15th preparatory
to a worldwide digital travel pass
internal passports for everybody linked
to your health status but not limited to
your health status if you can't see the
future in clear outline right now you're
not paying attention but the truckers in
canada can the canadian trucking
alliance estimates that roughly 16 000
truckers in canada are not vaccinated
that convoy also includes truckers who
are vaccinated but who aren't going to
stand for tyranny here's what the convoy
looks like
this started with vaccine mandates but
for most here it's about a lot more
i think this is more of a freedom
movement
[Music]
well over a thousand people lining the
trans-canada highway outside of winnipeg
in -30 wind chills protesting what they
call government overreach
somebody has to stand up for canada and
the truckers are doing it it all started
a couple days ago in delta bc truckers
protesting vaccine mandates at the
border
now as the convoy logs more kilometers
it's getting more support
we're just really tired of getting our
freedoms traveled on it's worth sticking
up for what you believe in
arriving outside winnipeg hundreds of
vehicles taking more than an hour to
pass
you came from calgary what do you think
of this
what are we doing
as it rambled by no one was hit it was
peaceful salvatore vetera has followed
since bc
it's a togetherness like i've never felt
before
and it keeps growing
and thank god it keeps growing
so what's the reaction been like from
our media gatekeepers well a cartoonist
for the washington post accuse the truck
drivers of fascism
there's the cartoon on your screen so a
paid vassal for the world's richest man
a man who supports censorship and
crushing anyone who doesn't agree with
him who treats his own legions of
workers like serfs
a guy who works for that man is telling
you that people who peacefully assemble
to express political opinions are called
fascists really who's the fascist pal
sheldon andreas is not a fascist he's a
pastor he's also a trucker he's a member
of the freedom convoy and we're grateful
to have him joining us tonight from
ontario mr andreas thanks so much for
coming on
uh fascist really um so tell us why
you're doing this if you would
yeah well
probably mostly for the same reasons
that a lot of these other guys are out
here doing this
uh there's just uh been a a stifling of
freedom and a stifling of unity in
canada for for two years a lot of a lot
of people are down a lot of people are
fired uh man you can't even go into a
grocery store without getting into an
argument about a mask or or whatnot
so what what really drove me to do this
is uh is the smiling faces that i seen
on the people that that organized it
like a good friend of mine helped to put
this together and uh
and it's just been wonderful to see all
the smiling faces that have come
together
it doesn't matter christians
non-christians all all sorts the the
natives are out with banging their drums
just a wonderful sensation to see unity
you know once again in canada
well it's it's beautiful to watch from
below your border i have to say you're
being snarled at but you're smiling back
the government seems to be doing all it
can to prevent you from peacefully
protesting its speaking of fascist
policies
but you're doing it anyway are you
worried about the repercussions
oh not at all not at all i mean some of
my friends have been arrested for
pastoring their churches we're fully
prepared to to to smile and push through
for for the greater good tucker we uh we
want to see
christ glorified in the church and out
of the church so we're pushing forward
come with me
so why
well i shouldn't even pose this to you
let me just say you seem much more like
a civil rights hero than a fascist to me
are any media in canada
supporting you or at least arguing that
you should have a right to express your
views
yeah not that i know of doctor i think
maybe rebel news is
putting out some positive stuff about
the about the movement but uh the
the mainline media is much the same in
the usa these guys are these guys are
not our friends they're they're coming
after us they're slandering really good
people and some of the stuff they're
saying about really good people dragging
their names through the mud it's
shameful
so uh no no fascists here moms and dads
and kids uh standing around a bonfire
beside me where this the convoy came
through here about
i don't know
half an hour ago uh standing here
you know with their with their kids
enjoying a joining a fire with people
they haven't you know got to hang out
with for a very long time
i got to say it's just so thrilling to
see this having watched canada such a
beautiful country a wonderful country
descend into this darkness
and to see someone like you standing up
cheerfully
is really affirming so thank you sheldon
andreas good luck yeah you're welcome
tucker thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else